greetings Homo sapiens and welcome to
reality check the show that delves into
the science of our video games and
explores the real-life fact behind the
playable fiction now as gamers we have
to admit that there are times that we
don't always agree sometimes our
favorite gaming platforms for example
the best battle royale game and whether
or not the y axis should be inverted it
should it's a joystick it's like flying
a plane
Ford is dead what's wrong with you
however there is one thing that we all
share go back far enough in time and we
are all descended from the same common
ancestor way back at the beginning of
our modern human species roughly 300
thousand years ago but what were our
ancestors like before this time before
mankind enter ancestors the humankind
Odyssey a new third-person open world
survival game where the player must
control and guide a group of early
primates helping them to explore expand
and ultimately evolve to advance to the
next generation so just what were a
pre-hearing ancestors really like and
what can we learn from playing ancestors
the humankind Odyssey
[Music]
so ancestors tracks are changed from ten
million years ago to roughly two million
years ago this is the period before we
became humans before we became the
homogeneous and it takes place in the
kind of cradle of humanity that is East
Africa the species that you're playing
in ancestors is not just our ancestors
but the ancestors of the gorillas and
the chimpanzees say hello to Simon what
they're the expert talking not the
primate on screen right now I have no
idea what his name is when I jumped into
play ancestors I was swamped with
questions about the reality of this time
period and the primate creatures
featured in the game fortunately I know
Simon and he is far too polite to ignore
my calls so started by asking him how do
we know anything about our ancestors ten
million years ago
piecing together what our early
ancestors might actually have looked
like is very very hard and we have to
use a combination of looking at the
fossils that remain but also trying to
infer what they might have been like by
comparing what we are like my of our
close relatives things like the
chimpanzees and our more distant
relatives even things like the monkeys
and the lemurs in the like behaviors
that we see that we have that they have
that is likely that our common ancestor
is also hot picking up behaviors during
my time playing ancestors one of my
proudest moments early on was learning
how to pick up sticks and stripping them
to then use as a tool for flipping over
rocks so I asked Simon is this tool
using kind of behavior something we
could expect that our ancestors were
capable of so the game shows an awful
lot of Tullius it chooses to even get
into an extent where our manufacturing
tools and holding them to do precise
jobs of course wouldn't Hills don't
really fossilized there are millions of
these things we can't see but we can
infer what might have happened by
looking at us and our common relatives
and we know that we do see this and some
of our cousin's things like the
chimpanzees some types of chimpanzee
they'll go hunting for things like
termites so they've got a stick that
they use to break into the mind and a
different stick with the use of trained
fish out and get those nice tasty grubs
once we're using things like storms
Hills were sharpened then we're giving
them an edge then we find many more
remnants because that kind of thing
sticks around in the fossil record
interesting stuff but it's not just
tools that ancestors exhibits our
primary plan making good use of as I
explored the Neogene jungle I carefully
studied the properties of numerous local
flora by cramming them in my ape face
I'll admit some of the effects were a
tad trippy but I was able to learn that
some had positive effects some helped
strengthen my bones while others aided
the clotting of my numerous wounds
allegedly I think she's just itchy so I
asked Simon how does this idea of our
ancestors self-medicating fit with the
science this is something we think it
likely that our ancestors actually did
one of the reasons for this is we look
at some of our cousin's monkeys lemurs
things like that we see that they very
similar behaviors there at fairs colobus
monkey for instance has been shown to
meet in charcoal to help its detoxifying
dangerous plants that might eat while
some species of capuchins in central
South America insurance beginning Piper
leaves and rubbing them over themselves
perhaps as a way of trying to deter
parasites get things have been living in
their fur and get them what finally for
me one of the stranger moments of my
time playing ancestors was when I
decided to pick and eat some leaves in
front of my clan only for them all to
copy exactly what I was doing
however from speaking to Simon I learned
that this was not some form of
prehistoric bullying but rather
ancestors demonstrating a really
important mechanism of how behavior can
be passed on so a species and an
individual can benefit by passing laws
genes but they can also pass on
knowledge arguably one of the things
which makes humans so special makes our
lineage so specialism we've also had a
cultural transmission whatever we learn
something we can pass it on to future
generations and keep that no engine
going within the cycle this really cool
studies coming out from Japan where they
were studying Japanese macaques and he
discovered that certain females that had
discovered things like you could wash
sweet potatoes to get the sand off them
to make and much tastier meal basically
that knowledge that discovery that she
made I wasn't so very descendants could
inherit genetically for that trait that
behavior that knowledge could be passed
on culturally the children learned it
and then the tribes of all learned it
[Music]
have you been playing ancestors the
humankind Odyssey and how far did you
get plus what questions came to your
mind while thinking about our real-life
ancestors from this period in time let
me know in the comments down below and
if you've yet to check out gameplay of
ancestors then there's loads right here
on GameSpot calm
[Music]